so
on this friday edition of pft live as we
get you ready for week four of the 2020
nfl season there are some very good
teams that have to go on the road this
week and one of the best teams in the
nfl the seattle seahawks has to go to
miami all the way across the country as
far as you can go and still stay in the
contiguous 48 u.s states from the upper
left corner all the way down to the
lower right corner you've got seattle at
miami and
the seahawks defense
not very good
ryan fitzpatrick last thursday night
pretty damn good do i smell a shootout
coming in south florida peter
i think it's going to be a high scoring
game i really do and
what i find interesting about games like
this
is and i wish i had looked up the
weather mic
look up the weather for uh miami gardens
florida and let's see what the humidity
is going to be on sunday
because
what is going to happen in this game is
that
you know the seattle seahawks are used
to playing
in a uh a very very nice
climate uh where it's never really that
hot
and uh and and it certainly wasn't you
know hasn't been for them so far this
year so now what happens if they come in
it's 88 degrees and and and really humid
at kickoff
and you got 27 guys getting ivs at
halftime
i'm almost not exaggerating you know
but i
any time a game like this happens at
this time of year
i think there's that chance
but i'll tell you the one other factor
in this game that i think is going to be
very interesting
and that is that
so seattle's secondary in my opinion
depending on what you have or what you
don't have with jamal adams
you know there are some big receivers
and some physical receivers
in you know in on the miami depth chart
and so those are the kind of receivers
that typically could give this team
trouble now
dk metcalf is going to give the miami
secondary a lot of trouble but i'm
saying on the other side
you're tempted just to say well russell
wilson is going to score in the 30s and
he probably will
but let's just see what happens you know
on the other side as well
here's what's scheduled for miami
gardens florida on sunday temperatures
in the mid 70s 47 chance of
precipitation humidity at kickoff 72
percent winds out of the southeast at 13
miles per hour not bad for a look at the
weather
i can pivot to meteorology peter that
may be more fun stand in front of a
green screen and pretend there's an
actual country there and you're doing
all this and look over here and look
down here no mike cantori florio
no thank you uh all right uh so look i
think the seahawks defense stinks and
it's got to be driving pete carroll
crazy as we've said time and again this
season he's a student of don not of don
coryell but of bud grant and that's one
of the reasons why i think pete carroll
resisted this let russ cook thing as
long as he did because you do
put your defense on the field more often
you do put more stress on your defense
and you do potentially put yourself in a
situation where your defense is among
the worst in the nfl statistically and
that's where the seahawks currently are
and that's what's so fascinating about
this game this screams out trap game it
just does
and you know that's when you have your
chance at taking down the great teams
the chiefs aren't going to stumble
against the ravens or the patriots
they're going to be fully focused and
ready to go against the ravens and the
patriots they're going to stumble
against the chargers they're going to
stumble against the raiders against the
teams where we just show up and win this
game and i think that's part of the
challenge for the seahawks this weekend
pete carroll keeping them focused on the
task at hand and understanding that even
though the dolphins are not the the
49ers or the rams or the packers or a
team that they should be
concerned about they they need to be
concerned because you know peter
something i said earlier this week with
with russell wilson having a dominant
performance a record-setting performance
usually in seasons like that the team is
winning easily
they're barely winning some of these
games
with russell wilson doing something
unprecedented because the defense just
can't hold up its end of the bargain so
they are in danger this weekend if brian
fitzpatrick is more fits magic than fits
tragic the seahawks are in danger this
weekend
you know add to this
uh you know just the fact that it's one
of these
10 o'clock body clock games for the
seahawks they'll be on an airplane for
six hours
come to miami
uh and uh and then they'll play at 10 am
body clock game
they've got four of those this year mike
obviously they won their first one
uh you know in week one but now they've
got two more after this in weeks nine
and 15.
so it's and look nobody's crying for
anybody
you know in the nfl with how they travel
but i do think the only time i ever
really pay attention to travel stories
is when for instance you know like what
the rams just did back and forth back
and forth to the east coast
you know that to me is a bit of a factor
but with seattle when you play so many
times at 10 o'clock on your body clock i
think eventually that's going to catch
up to you who knows if it'll be this
week
you mentioned week nine in week 15
week nine is the bills at one o'clock
eastern time i got a feeling that
between now and week nine that game ends
up 4 25 eastern peter i don't know the
rest of the details for that weekend
very good but
but that that that's a game that cries
out for
don't lump us in with the other one
o'clock eastern games and what a stretch
the seahawks have coming out of their by
at the cardinals the 49ers at the bills
at the rams and then the cardinals and
you may look at it and say all the
cardinals no the card the cardinals went
to seattle and beat them last year when
seattle was trying to still win the
division that that is a hell of a
stretch and that's the thing they're
going to be fully locked in for those
games they need to be fully locked in
for this game or that 3-0 is going to
become 3-1 the bills
trying to avoid going three and one
after that that great come from behind
after they gave up the huge lead win
over the rams on sunday they go to vegas
they're the second team to play in the
new stadium where the raiders took down
the saints
can josh allen keep this going i mean
it's it's fascinating to see it you know
i said on monday the difference between
him and patrick mahomes they do similar
things but mahomes seems like he's in
control allen seems like he's always on
that edge
of you know the bike careening into a
tree and he still finds a way to get it
done although every once in a while the
bike does hit the tree
can josh allen keep this going at this
rate that we've seen because he really
has been spectacular
well mike i think the big difference in
josh allen you know i talked to tony
romo who's one of his mentors uh this
off season and i talked to romo sunday
night and he said you know you got to
hand it to a guy who's an nfl
quarterback and he basically comes to
people like me and says how can i be
better he said he really is hungry to be
better and so he worked with jordan
palmer is his personal quarterback coach
in the offseason and he also got tutored
by tony romo
and the one thing that he has done mike
you know this is a guy who was a 58
passer in college
he was a 56 percent passer in his first
two years in the nfl but he went to
school so much on his mechanics this
offseason
that now he's a 71 percent passer
through three games and you know you
look at that and you say well you know
it's only three games and you're right
i'm not saying it's going to continue
but what i'm saying is
if you watch the way
that josh allen played in the first two
years versus the way he plays now you're
right
he's still a is a little bit of the guy
who's driving 10 miles an hour too fast
on a hairpin turn uh in a mountain
israel on a mountainous road however
just watch
the ease in which he makes so many of
his throws he's not trying to throw it
106 miles an hour he's not trying to be
the oldest chapman of football i know
that's hard for you to understand
because you don't know who our oldest
chapman is but he's the guy who throws
101 for the yankees but he's not trying
to be that anymore
he's just trying to be the guy who
completes the pass with touch
that's one of the things he learned this
off season and mike as i say i don't
know if it's going to continue but he's
looking like a totally different
quarterback through three games
i agree with you and one of the reasons
why the completion percentage is up he's
got a great
core of receivers for the first time in
his life he's got stefan diggs he's got
john brown he's got colby's and gabriel
davis has been a a steal of a fourth
round pick who's done very well the past
couple of weeks great catches against
the dolphins and against the rams here's
john gruden the guy who has to deal with
josh allen this week talking about the
big guy from wyoming who's coming into
his own
allen is a problem for everybody he can
make the throws that you can dream about
he's powerful he's got a rocket he's
hard to tackle he's smart
he's everything you're looking for at
the quarterback position and they've
surrounded him with an arsenal of good
players speed and the acquisition of
diggs gives them a guy that can really
hurt you down the field
we do a match-up draft every thursday
the matchups we're most interested in
for the coming week peter and i picked
derek carr versus josh allen in part
because of that vibe we just got from
gruden
if you play quarterback
for john gruden
he's always looking
for a better quarterback elsewhere and
he's always and this is something i've
learned from sims he's always talking in
the presence of his quarterback about
some other great quarterback and it's
got to piss you off see i don't hesitate
that time to say it it's got to piss you
off if you're derek carr you don't want
to hear about this other quarterback
that he thinks is so great because by
implication it means you're not
can i tell you one of the lessons
that josh allen learned this off season
in his uh conversations with with tony
romo
one of the things that romo believes
fervently is
you know you can complete a pass to a
running back on a wheel route and he can
gain three yards coming out of the
backfield
and it's marked down as a completion
and he got three yards so it's some
positive yardage but
if you threw that ball
to your running back in perfect stride
he could make 11 yards
so
that's the difference
one of the big differences in josh allen
he's throwing the ball to his receivers
where they can continue to make plays
mike
his yards per attempt is up two and a
half yards
per attempt that's a gigantic thing if
your yards per attempt i think it's 9.1
if your yard's per attempt is 9.1 you
know what that means
every time you take a snap from center
and you're in passing mode you're
getting a first down on average you know
yeah i mean so that is the big
difference this year with josh allen
much more accurate
and much more knowledgeable about what
it takes to run an offense and to keep
things going on offense now as you said
you said it early
he's got to get a little bit more
control of his temper and he can't be
you know getting penalties for saying
dumb things to officials and to other
teams so
that is still a work in progress with
josh allen
yeah and look this would be a good test
to them coming off of a very emotional
and draining win both physically and in
every other way possible going on the
road against a team that they saw get
dismantled by the new england patriots
can they keep their focus can they hold
it together can they get to four
and oh
all right
the baltimore ravens after getting
smacked in the mouth on monday night by
the kansas city chiefs stay fairly close
to home to take on a washington team
that is capable of being dangerous here
is lamar jackson the ravens quarterback
on the challenge of bouncing back after
losing to kansas city on monday night
is the sense this week that yes it was a
disappointing loss but look it's only
week three and there's a lot of football
left to play oh yeah for sure you know
it's
you know we hate the outcome of the game
but like like you said you know it's a
lot of a lot of football left this
season
gotta we can't dwell on it you know we
gotta move forward and focus on
washington now
i
is it cold enough for a winter coat he's
got the george costanza gore-tex coat
peter i i don't know i don't go outside
very much was it is there something
going on that i don't know about
well it's 56 degrees this morning in
brooklyn when i took the dog out for a
walk about six
so uh and i didn't have gore-tex i had a
hoodie but
uh yeah you could you could stretch and
go to gore-tex in the east right now
um look this really is
a a challenge for the ravens for one
very specific reason
when i talked to john harbaugh after
this dismantled the browns 38-6 to start
the season i said what have you done to
get your guys to forget about last year
because that's the bill belichick play
no matter what happens last year
it's done it's over you're zero and zero
you start over nothing that happened
last year means a damn thing this year
harbaugh said they haven't forgotten
about it they're talking about it they
want to talk about it they want to live
up to that standard they want to be as
good if not better than they were last
year
okay fine that's the aspiration
you just got reminded
that there's still a hell of a gap
between you and the chiefs you just got
reminded as lamar jackson admitted after
the game on monday night that the chiefs
are your kryptonite
i think it's going to take a lot and
peter there was a a montage that was
posted on the ravens twitter account of
all these guys on the sideline at the
end of the game trying to prop each
other up saying we will get it back
we'll get it back we got to refocus we
got i this is going to be this is going
to not be easy for them
after being humbled at a time when they
thought they were ready to establish
themselves when they were convinced that
they were going to be able to handle the
chiefs to get put back in their place
how do you want a short week
unfortunately they don't have to go
across the country it's not a long trip
at all but how do you get yourself
refocused to come back but how do you
get yourself refocused to come back and
assert yourself with the kind of
dominance we know they're capable of on
the heels of having that tough showing
that's going to be for me uh the real
challenge because if i recall correctly
i may need to go back and look at the
2019 schedule i think after they lost to
the chiefs last year i think the next
week they lost it home to the browns
which was far more of a stunning outcome
look mike there's two things
about both
monday night and about this coming
sunday that i think are really important
for this team
on monday
uh
coming right out of the box for the uh
you know for the third quarter they're
down 17 points
you know ronnie stanley your franchise
left tackle
misses a block
uh
a a block where he's one-on-one with
anthony hitchens the chiefs linebacker
and hitchens comes in and absolutely
decleats
mark ingram okay that's at the beginning
of the drive at the end of the drive
they got fourth and two they're all
excited they're deep in chiefs territory
they're going for it on fourth and two
this is the play that's going to get
them back in this game they'll have
scored right at the start of the second
half they'll be down 10 they'll be fired
up everything's good and what happens
orlando brown jumps false start they go
back they kick the field goal a chippy
field goal instead of going for the
touchdown and getting momentum
and i will just make this point about it
mike
it's very easy and very convenient to
say man lamar jackson you know terrible
awful cost us the game just not there he
just wasn't there if i'm john harbaugh
i walk into my team on wednesday morning
or zoom however they're doing their team
meetings and i would say
guys
this loss is on everybody
because we all
stunk
monday night
and that to me when i was watching that
game i kept saying the unfortunate thing
will be
that you know lamar jackson's gonna get
blamed for this and look
he's he deserves his share of blame
believe me anybody who watched that game
would understand that how he underthrew
marquise brown on the touchdown pass and
it was almost intercepted but
but that's a team loss that's one thing
the second thing i would say is
when you play washington
you've got to be careful about being
lulled into a false sense of security
thinking that this a lousy team
i mean
look at that defensive front
there aren't very many that are better
now they have had a couple of big
injuries there but still
that is a front that can give you
trouble and if they go into this saying
okay we're fine we're gonna rebound and
everything like that they're gonna get
punched in the jaw by washington i can
tell you and so we'll see how they
respond
and it was last year after losing in
kansas city a game they fell behind 17
points tried to come back and win it
realized they're not in the same class
as the chiefs they came home and they
got beat 40 to 25 by the cleveland
browns so this this isn't the classic
trap game this is the rebound game and
last year we saw what happened week four
to the ravens in that rebound game and
they need to be on guard they need to
dig deep on a short week to forget about
the chiefs and refocus and when you look
at what happened to the ravens last year
it took them a while to hit their stride
after losing those two games in a row
they almost lost to pittsburgh without
ben rothersberger had to take it to
overtime and just you know games that
they were winning by small margins and
then they started getting a little bit
better a little bit better and then by
november they were flat out dominant
that was uh really it culminated in that
shredding of the rams on monday night
football but the the ravens uh they've
got their work cut out for them this
week they're a 13-point favorite
and uh if it all falls together
and they play like they're capable of
playing peter they they win by 20.
but if if they don't
washington could beat them this week or
at least keep it very very close and i
just don't know which way that's going
to go for the ravens because
we don't know how they're going to
recover from having that bubble burst in
a very violent and dramatic and
conspicuous way on monday night football
if if i were the ravens and if i were
john harbaugh i'd almost want to face
some adversity in this game i really
would because sometimes it's too easy
for baltimore you know mike we talked
the other day and
and
and and this is the stat about lamar
jackson and these baltimore ravens
lamar started 27 games in his career
six times he's been behind at halftime
they're owing six in those games
he's won the other 21.
so what that tells me is he's a great
momentum player he's a great play from
ahead quarterback okay and you've got to
play well in the first half to get ahead
too
but what i'm saying is
i want lamar jackson if i'm john
harbaugh if i'm greg roman i want him to
face some adversity and i want him to
conquer that adversity
that is what we have not seen him do
and that's an excellent point for
another important reason to the extent
that there are narratives that are
hardening for this ravens team that need
to be changed the most important one is
oh and two for lamar jackson in the
postseason so they need to start turning
this around they need to come from
behind in the second half of the game
they need to do something to to allow
these isolated but very glaring defects
in an otherwise stellar
skill set
they've got to iron them out or they're
never going to achieve what they want to
achieve
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports